i never looked at my father like
straight in the face looking like this
like with whole full look
i feel like
maybe he thinks i was a mistake
for your own father not to look at you
in the face is strange
[Music]
all right what do you want to confess
today
okay so my secret is that if a guy tries
to ghost me or if i think i'm being
ghosted i will text them for my
girlfriend's number pretending to be a
different girl that they met out the
weekend before ask them what they're
doing and then show up where they are
have you ever actually done that yes 100
times it works literally every time and
what do you do when you meet up with
them
oh i just say hi i'm just like hey you
can't ghost me like i think it's fair to
ghost but you just can't go to me all
right what do you want to confess today
i am here to confess that to get my
current apartment i forged the paperwork
including the pay stubs primarily
because i had lost my job due to
pandemics and i was on unemployment and
our landlord was forcing us out so i
kind of had no choice because no one
would take me if i was on unemployment
so i just forged the pay stubs i pay my
rent on time every month so i see no
problem i
didn't buy my own snacks in college so
instead of doing that i would cut little
holes in the bottom of my roommate's
snack bags and steal them out the bottom
did she ever find out
to my knowledge she never found out did
you feel guilty doing it never i thought
someone should be eating the snacks
i want to confess the time that i stole
from my church
so i was very involved
in my church when i was like 10 or 11
and then i started working at like a
store where you could trade in bible
books for like actual toys or candy so i
was behind the counter of that and then
me and my friend conspired to steal all
the bible books and purchase the biggest
item in the store which was a race car
like an electric race car they knew that
it wasn't actually attainable like to
get that many bible books so we got into
trouble and then the next sunday i show
up at church and there's a cop he yells
at me my parents ground me take away all
my privileges it was
it was not a good experience definitely
some lessons learned
i'm a larper that's live action role
playing basically um grown men fighting
each other in equipment whatever the
theme is how'd you get into it um a huge
lord of the rings fan lived with three
guys my best friends in college who are
equally bigger fans one of them probably
the biggest lord of the rings nerd ever
he actually speaks elder scroll i wear a
15 pound steel helmet
and i use a sword which is aragon's
staff from lord of the rings and you
fight yeah we fight it's a huge field we
have a guild so our team's four people
there's a rule book it's called the
alliance rule book about 200 pages
it goes through everything what you can
do what you can't do what you can wear
[Music]
what do you want to confess today i want
to confess
apologies to my grandpa i once
accidentally perioded on his couch and
in a panic just flip the cushion
it's still there
we don't know what it looks like today
it was a few years ago
did he ever find out
nobody found out until this video i i
hope i hope grandpa doesn't watch lad
bible pretty lucky that uh the cushion
just flipped without yes oh my god it's
a disgusting green couch that was bought
in i think 1980. it was disgusting
before and now it's even more disgusting
and thankfully the cushion was the same
on both sides or at least it used to be
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you want to confess today so my
confession is that i kind of regret
having a sex change
uh i think that had i known
back in the day or 10 years from now
because it's not that i'm not that old
but you know if i would have known at
that time that my body was enough and
that
i could just be me in order to live my
truth and
not care about just the conditioning of
society and
you know all these heteronormatives of
what comes with the nature of being
trans i would have just you know kept
the body at but it is what it is but
yeah what message do you want to share
to maybe younger youth going through the
same thing
do your research i think it's very
important to do your research
really um
talk to a therapist
really figure out what you want for your
life
this is a huge decision it's not
something to just be played with you
cannot go back
you know
was it uh tough for you to confess that
yeah it's vulnerable it's something
that's you know
it kind of it kind of feels naked it
kind of feels like i'm naked right now
but i'm kind of feel like i was born to
be naked i was born to you know
metaphorically speaking yeah i mean that
way too you know i don't mind but you
know i just feel like you know i was
born to
say something and to speak out and to
use my voice in a way that's gonna
you know be honest
[Music]
what do you want to confess today
i killed my neighbor's cat and i never
told anyone
on purpose how
well i was six i was playing with its
whiskers and i thought they were way too
long and would be totally in its face
the whole time so i cut them
so when i was little i wanted to clean
my brother's fish tank so i put a bar of
soap in it and i murdered all of his
fish
and then a couple days later the cat
goes missing i see those missing posters
all over the neighborhood um anyone
missing on that fatal haircut day
mustache cut day basically how many fish
does he have or did he have he had like
five
and then we buried them in the backyard
and i never told him and then i asked my
dad like oh can you cut
a cat's whiskers and he goes what that's
a terrible idea don't ever do that
that's its navigation tool if you do
that it will get disoriented it's like
blindfolding a person never ever do that
and so i got terrified and realized that
i must have killed that cat by cutting
its whiskers you never told him
so what did he think happened to his
fish i don't know
i think they just got sick or something
i don't know so you had a little fish
funeral yeah
a lot of dead pet stories today
[Music]
all right what's your confession
my confession is that i'd like to kiss
all my guy friends girlfriends
how come
it's because they're attractive and i
guess throughout the years
i don't know i've hung out with them
and you get to know them
they become your friend
and then
you build an attraction
and
i guess it's something i've just been
playing with like the idea maybe i've
like ignored the first time the first
few times the first few years i'm like
okay they're pretty so what
well like they're pretty and i want to
do this but not that i would act on it
it's just the feeling what's the closest
you've come to
was probably just like flirting
like healthy flirting interacting with
them
do any of them know
no none of them know
and do your guy friends now
no none of the guy friends know
well do you want them to know yeah i
want uh me doing this is pretty much to
let everybody know
what do you want to confess today
so today i'm confessing um a secret that
i held on to for a long time from my
past and the secret was basically um
that i still harbored so many feelings
for my ex-boyfriend and felt like he was
the one
long after he broke up
took me so long to get over and i felt
like i went insane i
thought about him every day almost it
felt like i wrote letters from his
perspective to me trying to explain why
he may not reciprocate and i just felt
like he was the one like he was the one
who i would call on my future wedding
day to someone else
asking why i didn't work between us
but ultimately i felt like these
feelings would be a burden for him
because he had moved on
do you want to let him know
no i don't
because the one thing i learned from
that secret is that you'll never
get the answers you want from people
sometimes and sometimes when i look back
i don't know if i really did love him as
much as i thought i did for so long or
if it just became a habit and a pattern
to feel so
you know
to feel so in love with someone who
didn't
reciprocate
and i think if i did tell him now i
still wouldn't feel this level of
satisfaction that i think i would
[Music]
alright what do you want to confess
today
so a few summers ago my family and i
went to spain for a month and i had a
secret boyfriend
um i was just hanging out by myself and
we met he's from france and after that
almost every night i would sneak out
around 2 a.m
hang out go to like a bar get drinks um
just see like madrid and around 8 a.m i
would come back
and pretend i was sleeping and i never
got caught and my family does not know
until this day until right now
i never looked at my father like
straight in the face looking like this
like with whole full look
how's that make you feel
i feel like
maybe he thinks i was a mistake
because you're supposed to love your kid
you know i mean like whatever they want
to look like however they want to dress
and it seems like
my style makes him like
not see me
i guess as a man or whatever that means
i'm not saying that's what he's saying
but
for your own father not to look at you
in the face it's strange
goddamn
[Music]
i like to confess that i'm a sex addict
and i think about sex
every second of the day
pretty much
and how does that manifest itself in
relationships
seems to like i've never had a
relationship before because i'm
i'm scared of commitment